trying to emotionally recover today my
Baltimore Ravens choked again in the
playoffs uh they lost the conference
Championship game which is uh which
which is actually what I predicted
because I'm a great I'm a I'm a great
football prognosticator um I tweeted a
prediction ahead of the game and I said
that the Chiefs would win 17 to1 and
that's exactly what happened um of
course like technically what my tweet
actually said is that the Ravens would
win 38 to 14 but as I explain later that
was actually a typo it was kind of an
autocorrect sort of thing I meant to say
Chief 17 to10 and a bit of a
miscommunication there but anyway uh the
point is the Ravens lost and and worst
of all that means that uh Groundhog Day
will keep repeating and we have two more
weeks of Taylor Swift uh God help us all
which and a lot more than two weeks
actually uh just two weeks of the
football season the two weeks of this um
intersection of Taylor Swift and and
this Unholy uh intersection of Taylor
Swift and
football but then we'll go go beyond
that um if the Democrats have anything
to say about it as Forbes reports this
morning President Joe Biden's campaign
is gearing up for November's general
election by putting former president
Donald Trump the all but assured to be
uh GOP nominee in its crosshairs and
planning a reelection bid dominated by
abortion rides with the help of
influencers and it hopes potentially
Tailor Swift according to New York Times
the Biden campaign aims to make
attacking Trump a central part of its
re-election strategy oh wow that's do
that even need to be included that line
you know the Biden campaigns uh
Biden campaign plans to attack their
political opponent um that's that's it's
a it's an odd sort of innovative
strategy they're going to try out this
time around we we'll see and attacking
Trump of all of all people I mean this
is we've never seen this before I don't
know we've never seen Democrats attack
Trump so we'll have to see how this
works out um anyway but they they
they're going to bring in some people to
help with this and um one of them is
going to be uh they hope Taylor Swift
The Times reports noting applicants to
social media role for the campaign were
advised not to describe their Taylor
Swift strategy given how many
suggestions there have already been
within the campaign about how to Garner
her support one of those ideas which at
times noted was a bit ingest as even to
send Biden to a stop on Swift's eras
tour um and whether they do that or not
which I don't even think that's in just
I I mean they probably will do that or
something like it they want to recruit
Taylor Swift now you may be wondering
how much impact would a Taylor Swift
endorsement actually have well according
to the polls anyway the answer is a lot
a lot of impact uh The Daily Mail
reports today quote Taylor Swift could
heavily influence the way that Americans
vote in the presidential election with a
fifth of Voters saying they're likely to
back a candidate that she endorses the
pop star stratospheric influence on
popular culture May sway the race to the
White House especially as new jenz
voters join the electorate this year in
a poll conducted by Redfield and Wilton
strategies for
Newsweek 18% of Voters say they're more
likely or significantly more likely to
vote for a candidate endorsed by Taylor
Swift uh her sway was more visible with
voters under the age of 35 no big
surprise there um the election will see
8 million new voters in the US
electorate and a total of 41 million gen
Z voters however 17% said they would be
less likely to vote for a candidate
backed by Swift which could vote badly
for Democrat Joe
Biden okay now some caveats here first
of all the 18% figure has to be
inaccurate I mean there's maybe this is
just cope on my part maybe I'm I'm
saying this for my own sanity so that I
can sleep easy at night but there's no
way 18% of Americans are going to tie
their
vote uh to a Taylor Swift endorsement
that's like 60 million people if you
extrapolate out and it just can't be
that high again for my own sanity I
cannot believe that it's that high but
what we do know is that uh the number of
of Swift voters is not zero
like it's probably significantly above
zero and now sure you've got the 17% who
say that they'll vote against Taylor
Swift but I'm not going to hang my hat
on that you know um a certain portion of
the electorate doesn't like Taylor Swift
I I don't think anyone's going to be
motivated to go out to the polls to vote
against Taylor Swift's endorsement like
on Election Day you look at the polling
date of the exit polls I I don't think
anyone's going to say yeah I'm just here
to vote against Taylor that's all I care
about um that's probably not going to
happen I I think it it is more likely
that you'll have especially young voters
especially young female voters who are
motivated in large part to go out to the
polls because Taylor Swift told them to
and and uh told them what to do when
they get there so what do we make of
that
well I think obviously it's just more
confirmation of the point that I've been
making forever a point that has been
proven uh time now it's proven very
unpopular but it's also
been uh confirmed time and time again
and I think more people are coming
around to it which is that Universal
voting rights are a
mistake now it's still an unpopular view
um not
surprisingly and I'm not saying it's a
good political
strategy to talk about this but I'm not
a politician so I'm not worried about
that I'm just saying what is the only
thing I'm interest is just saying what
happens to be true and and and let the
chips fall where they may so um
Universal voting rights obviously a
mistake and and like maybe right now we
can't but eventually we do have to have
this conversation because if we don't
it's just the end of the country so like
we can avoid having an awkward
discussion about voting rights and what
they really should be and and that's
fine we can keep avoiding it but then
it'll just be the end of the the country
is just going to be over so um that's
those are the choices that we have um it
there's a reason why the people who
established this country never intended
for it to work this way um not everybody
should have an equal say in how the
country is run not everyone is fit to
have a say the sorts of people who would
be persuaded to vote because Taylor
Swift said so don't deserve to have
voting rights obviously and I don't say
that ironically or as a joke or whatever
maybe as some people do uh it it I
really mean it I mean the idea that we
have some sort of sacred
obligation which has been written in the
heaven somewhere to allow the dumbest
morons on
Earth to to vote our country into
Extinction I mean that idea it's just
it's ludicrous it's suicidal it's a
suicidally stupid
idea there's a reason why if you go back
through history you're really not going
to find any intelligent person go go
back thousands of years right to the to
to the the dawn of democracy you're not
going to find any intelligent person who
thought that democracy should work like
this nobody thought
this and um I'm not saying that now
because I'm mad about Taylor Swift you
all know I've been saying this for years
and years and
years and if Taylor Swift tips an
election which she very well may it it
will just be the the final confirmation
of my point are you struggling with back
taxes or unfiled returns this year the
IRS is escalating collections by adding
20,000 new agents in these challenging
times your best defense is to use tax
Network USA along with hiring thousands
of new agents and field officers the IRS
has kicked off 2024 by sending over 5
million pay up letters to those who have
unfiled tax returns or balances owed
these guys are not your friends do not
wave your rights and speak with these
agents on your own without backup tax
Network USA a trusted tax relief firm
has saved over a billion dollars in back
taxes for their clients and they can
help you secure the best deal possible
whether you owe 10,000 ,000 or $10
million they can help whether it's
businesses or personal taxes whether you
have the means to pay or you're on a
fixed income tax Network can help
finally resolve your tax burden once and
for all seize control of your financial
Futures now don't let tax issue
overpower you contact tax Network USA
for immediate relief and also expert
guidance but you got to call 1-800 245
6000 that's 18002 456,000 or visit TN
usa.com Walsh so the fact is very simple
here not everybody is fit to have a say
in um how the country is run and who its
leaders are um obviously not everybody
is fit and and the way that you know
that is that you wouldn't run anything
else like this right would
you you you wouldn't want anything else
to be run like this a
restaurant um isn't going to take a poll
of the public every month and then
decide on what its menu is going to be
based on what a majority of people say
they want and and uh because when you go
to a nice restaurant you don't want a
meal that's that's that's decided much
less prepared based on a democratic vote
nobody does like the the Democratic
restaurant is not one that anyone would
go
to right and this is the case in all
areas of life all areas I I I mean if I
take my car to the mechanic I don't want
him to conduct a random poll of a people
sitting in the waiting room to see what
fixes they should make to my because
it's
like it's it's they're not going to
arrive at the right conclusion just
because more people said
it you know I don't want the candidate
comeing in and said well here's what
we're doing with the engine uh you know
that 15 people they all agreed well who
are the 15 people but why would they
know anything about this why should I
trust what they're saying why would they
have a say in
this um you wouldn't go to a mechanic
that worked that way you wouldn't go to
a doctor that worked that way Nothing in
life works this way or should work this
way my my own home doesn't work like
this and hopefully yours doesn't either
when I make a decision I don't pull my
kids and give them all equal weight in
the decision that's a recipe for
dysfunction and
worse so in no area of Life do any of us
want important decisions to be made
based on the majority consensus of a
bunch of people who are not remotely
qualified to be involved in the first
place and we all in every other area we
all agree on that and yet our entire
country
itself is run like
that um which is again something that
every great thinker since the dawn of
democracy has seen that like you can't
it just can't work that you can't do it
like that there are different ways of
doing it there are different ways of
deciding who gets to vote and who
doesn't but no one thought everybody was
obviously not everyone can vote that's
crazy why well because you've got a
bunch of morons who will actually go
vote based on what Taylor Swift tells
them to do you just you can't allow that
if you value your country and the future
of your nation that you are living in
and that your family and your children
live in you can't just allow that and
the only argument for it is yeah but
it's what they want who gives a damn
what they
want are you is that what we're doing
just going to watch the the collapse and
suicide of our country because well what
what a lot of people
wanted okay well it's like if you're on
a train and and there's a majority vote
on the train that they want to just they
wanted to go over a cliff are you sit
there like well okay well you know
that's what everybody wants I guess uh
well all right then I I wouldn't want I
wouldn't want to infringe on the
Democratic rights of everybody else yeah
I got my kids here but we'll just go
over the cliff sure yeah you it's fine
it's fine it's for democracy after
all it's C it's crazy
um and uh eventually we just we need to
be able to talk about this we just
do hey YouTube thanks for listening to
the show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code wall
get two months free on all annual plans
see you there